alright guys really important a story
about propaganda the manufacturer of
consent
foreign policy could not be a better
example early in this new year of how
monetization policy on large platforms
like YouTube can actually help the right
beat the drums towards war so it's
actually interesting that it's happening
so early in the new year very often in
the new year monetization goes down
because a lot of advertisers spent a lot
of their money in the fourth quarter of
the previous year and often in the first
and second quarter advertisers are more
cautious with their budgets they want to
make sure that they save ad money for
later in 2020 so quick recap a lot of
creators like the david pakman show put
our videos on YouTube we make money when
people watch the youtubes and the
YouTube videos and advertisements play
and the primary way we make money is
that an ad plays before our video clip
people watch the ad we get paid then our
clip starts everybody's sort of happy
there are guidelines for what is
monetizable you can't do videos about
certain things and run ads on them
because they are not considered brand
safe and the way it was supposed to work
was you know over racism violent and
gory videos fight videos there were
things that weren't monetizable and they
basically made sense but over the last
18 months this has come to really impact
news and politics channels I have had
conversations with YouTube employees who
have told me for example anything on
abortion is not monetizable now you know
it's not a hard and fast rule in
practice there are many videos on
YouTube about abortion abortion that are
monetized maybe they refer to abortion
only tangentially maybe they're super
clean in their language maybe the
YouTube algorithm just missed it and
allowed ads to run but in principle
videos about abortion are not brand safe
on YouTube by and large another example
there's some one prominent that died
recently officially by suicide but some
people don't believe that this person
died by suicide if you talk about that
person I've been told by YouTube the
video is non monetizable even if you
reference the
person's name absent any details about
why they are prominent I think people
know who I'm talking about if you
mentioned that person's name the video
can't be monetized sometimes things slip
through but this is at least the policy
that I've been told many of you can
probably tell where I'm going with this
we now have one of the major stories of
the last many years which is that our
president is starting to barrel towards
a misguided and completely backwards war
against Iran this content is basically
not monetizable on YouTube and that is a
soft way it's an indirect way in which
the monetization can influence the
manufacture of consent for war with Iran
and by virtue and extension of that can
influence American foreign policy every
day every news channel on YouTube
corporate ones like CNN and Fox
independent ones like us and many others
we decide what is worthy of coverage
that day today's show is mostly Iran
because we might be going to war again
in another incorrect misguided war for
political benefit we have to cover it
it's huge
but most of these clips are demonetised
because they refer to a current military
conflict which is one of those areas
that is vaguely identified by YouTube as
not monetizable now I know that some of
you will see ads on some of the clips on
our channel and on others there are
clips that are slipping through and we
never really know why one is monetized
and another is not the algorithm is
opaque it doesn't work perfectly but if
you are CNN you can either just have a
different ad deal on YouTube where you
can monetize everything we don't have
that we don't have that privilege but if
you're as big as CNN or as big as Fox
News you're so big that YouTube is a
small piece of your revenue and you
don't care so CNN and Fox News and other
corporate media they can cover the
run-up to possible war with Iran with no
serious negative repercussions because
they don't depend on YouTube revenue
with us when we cover what's going on
with Iran we lose financially again if
the algorithm catches us it's still
early in the Iran thing and there are
videos that are getting through and
being monetized but I've talked to other
Creators who say
I'm getting a lot of Iran stuff
demonetised but every single day we get
closer to it being policy where YouTube
says advertisers don't want to touch the
Iran war as it may one day be if you
talk about Iran much like for a while if
you talked about Syria
you get demonetised so it puts creators
in the position of saying do I want to
cover the right stuff today which is
Iran or do I want to make money so I can
pay staff and connectivity and studio
rent we have some other revenue sources
so my plan is to do all of the Iran
coverage that I believe makes sense and
right now it's a hell of a lot but we
are going to take a hit other shows may
be less diversified in terms of revenue
they may not be able to do all the Iran
coverage they think is proper and remain
viable and this is how foreign policy
gets influenced this is how consent is
manufactured some of the strongest anti
war in Iran voices are independent
voices who are increasingly going to be
unable to make money putting out their
content which will influence at least
some of these voices to say you know
what I've got to talk about something
else instead of doing an hour on Iran
I'll do 15 minutes on Iran and 45
minutes about other stuff this is part
of the process of manufacturing consent
YouTube is not saying to be clear let's
do monetize Iran content so that we have
fewer anti-war voices so that we go to
war with Iran
that's not YouTube's priority it's
simply money for them but it has the
effect of limiting independent anti-war
voices so that the predominant ones
remain corporate voices many of which
basically just cheerlead the
military-industrial complex and the
foreign policy apparatus that donald
trump represents so when i say hey you
know you should really fund shows that
you like directly get a membership at
join pakman.com for a few bucks i'm
literally saying to you the system in
place dis encourages disincentivizes
shows like ours and others from covering
the insanity of the beating of drums
towards
with Iran that are increasingly being
hit when you sign up you were saying
cover what matters not what's
monetizable that's my position on this
that's my place in this so this is
serious stuff and it matters hugely this
is one of the ways a manufactured that
this is one of the ways that you see
consent manufactured in media it limits
information that is vital to people's
decision-making if the average person
who's busy living their life wants to
decide what is it that should happen
with Iran should I be writing my member
of Congress saying let's go get him or
should I be writing my member of
Congress saying I will vote you out if
you don't get in the way of Donald Trump
doing this if you have an entire wing of
anti-war voices that just lose money if
they talk about it you are putting an
obstacle there to present people with
both sides of the story including I
would argue the important side which is
we're doing this again we just did this
with Iraq in 2002 in 2003
we're really going to do the same thing
on corporate media with the same people
Ari Fleischer and who else was it that I
saw being interviewed due to other
people that were saying we've got the
evidence and Saddam is linked to 9/11
and he's got uranium and all this stuff
didn't have it the WMDs weren't there
the same people are being brought on to
manufacture consent and the soft way to
disincentivize the anti-war voices you
know MSNBC fired Phil Donahue when he
was the only anti-war voice in 2002-2003
against Iraq now it can be done in a
very different way just by D monetizing
people who want to talk about this
conflict we'll keep talking about it my
ask is support us directly by grabbing a
membership at join pakman.com